chairman were the first to fall as
bizarre as it was baffling it was
decreed they should hence would be
referred to as chairs Oh to be a round
of boardroom table if only to hear it
announced following approval from the
cabinet the chair tabled the motion head
masters and mistresses swiftly followed
they're all head teachers now just as
restaurant manager s's and spokeswoman
have all been done away with and I'm
still not sure if I'm allowed to say
actress but the latest victim of this
ludicrous and confection gender-neutral
campaigning is wait for it father
Christmas one month from Plymouth found
herself shamed on social media after
discussing the book entitled father
Christmas but she was piously informed
only the name Santa Claus is deemed
appropriate now while I believe in
father Christmas and kids he does exist
don't listen to grumpy and naughty
people who suggest otherwise I cannot
subscribe to this seasonal stupidity
call him father Christmas and Nick or
Santa it doesn't matter this is not so
much ho ho ho as no no you know sort of
this stuff now it's bordering on the
moronic there was a survey recently that
said 15 percent of people want to change
father Santa to agenda for the Christmas
percentage yes yes yes and that means
that 85 percent of people do not you
know the cerrado a really good story
last year and it was it was the Church
of England canon and she said that the
the tivity player in the local schools
they couldn't refer to three wise
through as men they had to say three
wise people jokingly said oh Allah we
got we've got to look out for next year
because they'll be looking to make
father Christmas gender-neutral and here
we are
Nicholas okay it came to pass why do you
care so much because because it's a
tradition
father Christmas was a bloke we can't
make a mother Christmas because it
wasn't its father Christmas I'm gonna
change that surely he's been invented by
people you people like use we're good
old time
you wouldn't you seriously don't think
we should effectively check sighs the
words father Christmas do you must
replace the way it's called Santa cool
Center have you ever been father
Christmas yes I don't think you know the
Scottish Parliament have outlawed all
staff referring to gingerbread men as a
min you have to say gingerbread people
this is a biscuit we're talking about I
mean this is what you said about wise
men on that particular one I don't see
the problem with what I mean because if
they're being men isn't integral to the
story if you change it if you change
jobs if you change things if you change
Joseph them indicative in Queens if you
change Joseph that would fundamentally
change the story if what Kings Kings
historical fact that we had Caspar
Melchior and Balthazar actually people
who existed and were written about yeah
this is what the nativity play
representing I would ago didn't you
change you know I would I would agree
with that how do you at that point my
point is that in general if the / if the
gender of the person isn't relevant to
the story then it's fine to change it so
with Santa I don't think you should
change it I think you I think he's known
as would you say why would you be
offended by father Christmas I mean and
if you are offended toughness icon.this
I mean I was trying to think my way
around it and I think that the only
reason why there may be some value in
maybe making father Christmas gender
neutral or even mother Christmas and
then I can say basically if you think
about father Christmas in most countries
and certainly in this one it is the
woman who does the cooking in the
shopping and the clearing up most of the
time and then you've got father
Christmas who's the one who comes in it
takes the glory and the credit and
though everyone loves father Christmas
and he's very jolly because he hasn't
livering his pants but actually we know
what goes on behind the scenes yes we do
and that's exactly and I think what
we're seeing is the sort of a reaction
against the reality of the work of the
work different workload in Christmas you
want to give women more credit so I
think I think it's kind of like the
thing where you have with superheroes
the fact that not enough
traditionally superheroes were written
for female roles and therefore if you
want to get more women into into the
comic book book genre you have to sort
of change the gender and that sort of
thing similarly I think it's about
finding those new roles for people for
example the M&S ad for showed how the
mother Christmas it was named is that
mrs. Claus
she was integral to the actual work done
by Santa so you actually increase the
value of the female role rather than
replacing the male role but why are we
bringing political correctness because
identity politics has infused and
infested every single part of life yes I
mean not even Christmas is sacred but I
think I think it should be that's my
argument because of the story you
objected to chim yeah I think chair is
ludicrous I mean why because it can be a
man or it can be able I got to be a
chairman or chairwoman I don't
understand why can't I get to be a chair
imagine bringing your wife or young
Darya Spencer I've just become a chair
god it's ridiculous and it Carol let's
just later call Gina Bhatia she's an
LGBT consultant let's see what she has
to say about it we don't need to give
father Christmas a gender-neutral name
father christmas is a tradition and if
we start questioning Santa's gender well
surely that means we have to go back and
question all the other historical
characters and traditions too you see
and it's interesting that you know what
there's been a story recently about the
census yes that's right about whether
people should be you know if you know
whether you say what you were born as or
what you identify your sexuality then
you asking but it's interesting that
there might be this is a it's voluntary
for over six C's the LGBT Foundation
recently complained that there are
multiple barriers fought for people to
access for trans people to access the
poor support services because there's
not enough data about them yeah and this
census will actually stop us getting
correct data if it goes through tonight
I need to come back on that from the
LGBT charity who say on this point there
remains a complete lack of accurate
population data for trans people
this makes the provision of effective
services supporting and meeting the
needs of the community more challenging
whilst there remains progress to me made
the 2021 census is nonetheless an
important step in ensuring that we live
in a society where trans people are
treated with the same dignity and
respect afforded to everybody else has
Emma Meehan from the LGBT Foundation
charity I think great you won't commit
well I I understand that because
actually I suspect the number they'll
find these tiny compared to but I
remember the last sense of maybe the
satyrs before my kids or when he wrote
Daniel didn't know your religion 10% of
the population became their religions
Jedi what is the question good of
Emerson and also what are the options
they give you do they say what were you
a natural born that's what you
identified well it's been determines is
2021 so they're still working out with
each other but if it comes the whole
point is it's what you identify as
that's what people are have been
triggered by that won't work so you
don't get accurate date of it well no
for the provision of paternity units we
can't have people I need to know how
many women I'm correct in saying is the
quest is going to be what gender do
identify that's what Carol and I saying
is that won't work that won't give you
accurate data we have to remember that
there is a difference between gender and
sex right so if you see if you say
identify us this gender that doesn't
change your sex yeah you've got a no
we're gonna build maternity unit so
there's no point a man saying you know I
feel respect for these people but you've
got to know who actually is a woman
because then you can provide that
yes yeah yeah that's gender yeah she's
gonna have a sex and agender quest
review the census doesn't exist to
validate people's identities it's about
accurate information about how many
given them Gibbs and me given these
given the specific needs of trans people
you need to include that in the
consensus surely you in there but it's
useful and interesting information to
have given that you were saying that you
know it's ridiculous that the trans
Lobby has hijacked various arguments
well actually we can find out how big
the trans Lobby or the trans population
is yeah which will be a good thing